let's have a look at this and opposite
the previous lesson they just did I
think you'll find they're super epic
fresh air another complicated algebraic
yeah we've already met we've already met
the rectangular hyperbola just kind of
look there's a couple of it speeches and
then I'll be able to recognize it in the
future
okay so do you recall what is it that
defines what is it that makes the
rectangular block rotate them the
absolute eyes are at right angles
in other words there are retained okay
so if you have the asymptotes at right
angles algebraically what that means is
that instead of x squared over a squared
- wife's way don't be square we're gonna
have a and B being identical does that
make sense so in other words remember
all we're saying a B they are about how
much you stretch out horizontally and
stretch out vertically so this means you
are stretching out at exactly the same
time
does that make sense let's draw a brief
picture of this thing
now before we put this thing on I want
to make sure this is accurate and
therefore I want to put the asymptotes
first rather than after the fact because
just generally speaking when I myself
brawl by freehand if I don't park like
that 99% of the time I end up with
something kind of parabolic right in
otherwise it won't approach asymptote
right it's going to cut away from
asymptotes so therefore it's in my
interest to put the asymptotes on first
now knowing that they are at right
angles we showed before that the two
asymptotes for this guy are going to be
y equals plus or minus X right here's y
equals x and I'm gonna have y equals
minus X
going down here okay what other features
can we read off from the equation of the
line okay I can read off the
directorships and I can also read off
the foci and lastly I can read off the
intercepts right now for the purposes of
graphene out of those three probably the
most important ones are the promise in
the intercept put on a pass through the
right so how do I work out the excepts
listening okay so x equals 0 for this
particular hyperbola because oriented
this way x equals 0 will have those
solutions so we knew that already so
therefore for y equals 0 this term
disappears
you're getting x squared equals a
squared so the two values you're going
to get are x equals plus or minus okay
so I'm just going to label that as a and
that has
in theory now even though I should put
up my directrix and also my focus as
well in theory now I have enough to draw
the shape at least accurately right so
the way I did to do it is remembering
that at these two vertices right it
turns around the horizontally so I draw
a vertical line there like this you've
got a vertical tangent at those points
and then I approach that asset type
identity profile in order to start
poking it and I do the same thing
over here
interesting
say deal unless so enjoy I've got the
medical ready I will approach the
acetone on bottom and I will first yes
I'm turning and there is a beautiful
rectangular hyperbola okay
you will notice just have a careful look
at the curvature
do you see it's a lot shallower than had
I just drawn this freehand like I said
I'd usually end up drawing parabolas and
on aperture that's intense at all these
are getting steeper and steeper and
steeper forever okay let's go what I
want so that's why putting in these
asymptotes is very critical to getting
the accuracy of your I've ever loved
okay like I said we can add on our arm
directory shoes and fort I'm worried
about that a bit later
right now I want to point out kind of
the important the other important detail
about this which is that remember if I
gave you any line per block and I said
okay tell me something about this what's
the first thing you write down to work
out like my vision likewise
the first thing you write down is that
identity that equation which connects
the two proportions with the
eccentricity right now usually that
starts with a B Square but I don't have
a B Square so I'm gonna write a squared
equals B squared outside all now it's a
hyperbola right so good so e squared
minus 1 because we recall that in order
the extra study starts from right there
right yeah it starts with a circle then
it goes to the ellipse then the parabola
then the hyperbola so that I purple is
gonna have the biggest eccentricity it's
easy ending ones so that's why it has to
be so that's that's a very bad unit
that's what has to come first
okay now I can divide through by a
squared right so I'm going to get 1
equals e squared minus 1 so they're
making these squared the subject I get
this because the eccentricity is a ratio
between two positive things I can just
say well there's one value of
eccentricity
because exorcism is positive
have even
I see what you mean
not because we saw that exigency in
creating the zero is kind of a weird
special case it actually kind of breaks
the definition of what execution is
right we saw that if you you know when I
honor go down that road right and you
see okay well if I level off my section
I'll get the circle so the circle is a
conic section but you simply cannot put
0 into the exigency it's a ratio by
definition so even though I said e
equals zero I really should say it but
limit as a approaches 0 is this okay but
econo
I see what you mean yes it's true
because I define this as a hyperbola
however all I'm trying to exclude is
negative or a tooth it's just a negative
like I'm just trying to look at a square
root and saying which one do I want
he is great that one is true but I don't
need to appeal to the fact of his son
but this is a hyperbola so draw a
conclusion okay so all rectangular
hyperbola everything one has an
eccentricity of Richard